[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
dans ce nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actu parlementaire au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale et cette semaine
notre invité pour commenter toute cette
semaine
et bien c'est luc carvounas vous êtes
député socialiste du val-de-marne
bonjour et on commence avec votre carte
d'identité witam luc carvounas vous êtes
né à charenton-le-pont vous êtes députée
du val-de-marne depuis 2010 est vous
avez été auparavant sénateur socialiste
un jeune sénateur de 40 ans vous avez
aussi été maire d'alfortville bas c'est
vrai sur vos terres du val de marne et
en 2017 vous avez été parmi la
soixantaine de députés qui n'ont pas
accordé la confiance à edouard philippe
en juin 2019 vous ne votez pas non plus
vous restez sur votre ligne de députés
d'opposition ce qui n'est pas forcément
le cas de certains de vos anciens
collègues socialistes vous tiendrez
cette ligne de député socialiste
opposition bah moi j'ai reçu un mandat
de la part des électeurs de ma
circonscription j'étais très qu'à mon
slogan c'était la gauche de combat
j'ai été élu sur ce thème là et j'essaie
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée de porter leur
voix et moi ce que je constate c'est
qu'entre les deux votes liés au discours
de politique générale nous étions je
crois sexe ça se compter sur les doigts
d'une main au groupe socialiste à avoir
voté contre et vingt deux ans plus tard
est resté sûr nous avons fait cause
commune nous sommes majoritaires je m'en
réjouis
je suis un député d'opposition je peux
pas en étant de gauche me retrouver dans
une politique de droite libérale c'est
pas possible eh bien on va maintenant et
bien pour repasser en revue et bien
toute cette semaine parlementaire
christophe castaner sous le feu des
questions le ministre de l'intérieur
était auditionné à l'assemblée puis au
sénat après l'attentât contre la
préfecture de police de paris
l'immigration sujet de débat au
parlement le gouvernement exposer sa
politique migratoire devant députés et
sénateurs débat sans vote au regret de
certains
le projet de loi sur le statut de l'élu
a commencé son examen au sénat
objectif renforcer la commune et
améliorer le statut des mers et on
commence par le premier thème de cette
émission christophe castaner face aux
questions des sénateurs
[Musique]
une semaine après l'attentât de la
préfecture de police de paris christophe
castaner et son secrétaire d'état
laurent nunez ont longuement répondu aux
questions des parlementaires
retour sur cette audition avec adrien de
voler l'audition aura duré deux heures
deux heures pendant lesquelles
christophe castaner et laurent nunez ont
répondu aux sénateurs de la commission
des lois
beaucoup de questions plusieurs mises en
cause suite à l' attaque de la
préfecture de police de paris la semaine
dernière pour le gouvernement aucun
doute
l'arsenal législatif pour détecter toute
radicalisation existent déjà aux
fonctionnaires de l'appliquer j'ai
demandé à l'ensemble de nos forces comme
le préfet de police qui l'a fait par
note a demandé à l'ensemble des agents
la préfecture de police de faire en
sorte que tous les signes a relevé le
soin et fassent l'objet d'un signalement
je considère que c'est la responsabilité
d'un policier ou d'un gendarme d'assumer
la dénonciation de phénomènes de
radicalisation qu ils constateraient et
pour moi ce n'est pas négociable
y compris un signalement khalil doit
être pris en compte quand il est gras
d'oie est prêt en contre une partie des
questions s'est porté sur le rétro
criblage un processus qui permet de
revenir sur l'ensemble des antécédents
professionnels et privés d'un individu
et qui peut conduire à sa révocation
les sénateurs ont interrogé le ministre
sur la lenteur de sa mise en place
c'est une loi du 30 octobre 2017
je vous le dis madame la sénatrice
pleurait trop pliage rétro criblage
existe et fonctionne pourquoi nous ne
l'avons pas utiliser parce que jusqu'à
présent nous n'en avons pas eu besoin
en gage de bonne foi christophe castaner
alors livré à la commission des lois un
état des lieux des procédures pour
radicalisation dans les forces de
l'ordre
ce que je sais c'est qu'au moment où je
vous parle il ya une quarantaine de cas
de signaler dans la police nationale si
cas de révocation est engagé il en reste
dix neuf
selon les chiffres qui m'ont été
contactées qui ont fait l'objet d'un
signalement mais dont les autorités ont
considéré que le signalement n'était pas
caractéristique d'une radicalisation
la commission des lois devrait faire des
recommandations législatives pour lutter
contre la radicalisation dans le secteur
public
et même si pour le gouvernement des lois
efficaces existent déjà
les ministres ont confirmé la mise en
place d'une enquête complémentaire
luc carvounas est-ce que vous jugez
qu'aujourd'hui il faut prévoir et bien
de nouvelles lois sur la radicalisation
dans la fonction publique notamment
déjà je veux dire d'un mot parce que
j'étais à l'hommage aux policiers à la
préfecture de police de paris nous
étions nombreux c'est la france toute
entière qui a été en deuil
et c'est un drame et ce drame nous
oblige tous les responsables politiques
à ne pas rentrer sur un sujet comme
celui là sur de la politique
politicienne comme certains ont
peut-être tendance à le faire
ensuite moi je me souviens avoir planché
sur les questions de radicalisme
notamment dans les collectivités
territoriales et dans un rapport que
j'ai produit avec jean marie bockel au
sénat lorsque j'étais sénateurs
mettaient même aller à à molenbeek pour
comprendre en belgique en belgique tout
à fait au lieu de la radicalisation ce
sont des sujets extrêmement compliqué
pour toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont
en général confronté évidemment les
maires et ensuite les pouvoirs publics
je me souviens que tout de suite après
les attentats 2015 qu'est ce qui s'est
passé toutes les préfectures ont mis en
place des réunions avec des références
sur la laïcité dans les services publics
donc rien n'a pas été fait mais est ce
que justement les nerfs suffisamment
armé aujourd'hui toutes les manières
face à l'islamisme radical
quoi qu'on fasse si quelqu'un devant
vous est persuadé qu'il va faire
l'attentât sera toujours difficile donc
il faut mettre toute un série de
dispositifs mais surtout le maître mot
c'est des moyens en fait des moyens dans
les collectivités territoriales et on en
a de moins en moins des moyens dans le
renseignement et ce qui s'est passé il
ya dix ans la réorganisation du
renseignement entre renseignements
territoriale en ciment national pour
citer in est rare cette réorganisation a
mis dans tous les cas hiatus entre ceux
qui sont sur le terrain au plus près de
la connaissance de ce qui se passe et on
va dire les sachants la haute
administration qui peut-être ne reçoit
pas bien
les signaux d'alerté moi à l'époque je
continue à le dire je pense que les
mères on est à quelques mois d'une
élection une idée des élections
municipales qui sont le premier guichet
républicain il faut les associer à ce
que l'on appelle les fichiers sd c'est
toujours pas le cas ils sont toujours
pas une section passionné toujours pas
s'ils nous demandent notamment d'hervé
maurey au cemat les mères avec leurs
services municipaux avec les
associations avec les enseignants dans
les écoles les chefs d'établissement
nous avons tout le système et les
réseaux au plus près du territoire de
nos concitoyens pour être des lanceurs
d'alert après il faut que ça fonctionne
mais relanceur dallas venez vous dis
c'est une erreur de ne pas les associer
c'est une erreur bien sûr que c'est une
erreur le maire quitte officier de
l'état civil et donc représentant de
l'état et le premier magistrat de la
commune a moins accès à des données
essentielles qu'un haut fonctionnaire
qui planche sur les mêmes sujets les
mêmes questions est ce que c'est normal
moi je dis pas de donner les listes
parce que c'est ça qu'on aurait tort
jamais d'accord si on donne des listes à
tout le monde
il pourrait y avoir un dévoiement sais
pas ce que je demande mais on peut se
mettre dans des comités de pilotage ni
travaillaient tous la main dans la main
en tous les cas
encore une fois ce drame nous oblige il
faut que le législateur mais pas que le
législateur il faut aussi entendre les
élus des collectivités qui se
retroussent les manches au quotidien
tout à fait alors avant de retrouver les
sénateurs christophe castaner a été
entendue à l'assemblée l'opposition
notamment de droite avaient beaucoup de
questions à lui poser eric ciotti lui a
notamment reproché d'avoir parlé trop
vite en disant très vite que le tueur
n'avait jamais présenté de difficultés
de comportement écouter la commission d'
enquête qui va se mettre en place un
board aura dans la sérénité la
responsabilité toute la chaîne qui a
conduit à cette tragédie
mais je veux vous poser une question
plus personnelle
vos propos hâtifs je le redis et ça a
été soulignée ont altéré la crédibilité
de votre fonction
regrettez-vous ces propos qui ont altéré
la crédibilité de votre fonction
monsieur eric ciotti
quand je dis la vérité des éléments qui
étaient connues au moment où je
m'exprime et c'est la responsabilité qui
est la nôtre c'est de dire toute la
vérité de ce que nous connaissons
christophe castaner après ces événements
at-il encore l'autorité pour rester à
son poste de ministre de l'intérieur
moi vous savez je n'ai jamais dans ma
vie politique demandé la tête de qui que
ce soit d'abord dans l'oeil avec des
failles des dysfonctionnements départ
qu'il ne relève pas du ministre de
l'intérieur au moment donné être dans
l'opposition c'est pas non plus dire
n'importe quoi donc je suis extrêmement
vigilants à cela s qui l'a exclu at il
dit n'importe quoi pour qu'est-ce qu'il
fait de la politique politicienne
bon voila moi je n'y aurais pas sur ce
chemin là après est-ce que christophe
castaner a été plutôt c'est là la
question bien conseillé par son cabinet
et par les éléments d'information est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas plutôt dû dire dans
ce qu'on appelle à la décision ou
ministre l'intérieur
white white way t'attendons un petit peu
on n'a pas tous les éléments bon
peut-être que il a aussi une coutume
c'est pas une critique c'est un fait ils
communiquent souvent vite christophe
castaner et souvent par tweet luc
carvounas vous l'avez dit vous étiez à
l'hommage à la préfecture emmanuel
macron a pris la parole à ce moment là
il a parlé de l'hydre islamiste et appel
à une société de la vigilance est ce que
vous craignez aussi qu'on puisse se
mettre à stigmatiser les musulmans avec
ce type de discours est ce que faut
aussi faire attention à cela
mais ce sont nos amis musulmans dans le
territoire qui nous le disent tout ce
climat est très anxiogène mais il date
pas de ce drame et la date maintenant de
tous les attentats et nous avons une
deux voire
de les protéger l'islam est la deuxième
religion de france aujourd'hui il faut
en avoir conscience et donc il faut
dialoguer il faut aussi ne pas jeter
l'anathème
après j'ai entendu le bayan société de
la suspicion aussi à l'égard du joueur
j'ai entendu le discours du président de
la république qui était un discours
l'hydre islamiste et fort comme mot
quand même oui bon côté le président
macron qui cherche à avoir des formules
qui font parler d'elles la preuve vous
me questionner sur cela maintenant
j'attends aussi d'un président et d'un
gouvernement qu'on nous dise très
clairement sur quel chemin nous allons
quelle leçon nous retirons de ce drame
et comment nous allons pouvoir empêcher
autant faire se peut encore une fois
avec beaucoup de l'application ans que
je dis que ça ne se reproduise plus un
discours constructif
alors cette semaine le carvounas députés
les sénateurs ont parlé d'un sujet de
fond l'immigration
[Musique]
deux débats sur la politique migratoire
de la france et de l'europe au sénat et
à l'assemblée pas d'annoncés concrètes
mais deux sujets au coeur des
préoccupations du gouvernement l'aide
médicale d'état
et l'idée d'instaurer ou pas des quotas
pour l'immigration fanny day ce débat
c'est emmanuel macron qu'il a voulu
convaincu que ce thème sera au coeur de
la prochaine élection présidentielle
le président voulait montrer que le
sujet n'est pas réservé à la droite ou à
l'extrême droite dans un hémicycle
clairsemé le débat confirme les profonds
clivages entre le gouvernement et les
oppositions sur l'immigration pas
d'annoncés concrètes mais le premier
ministre ouvre la réflexion sur les
quotas je n'ai pas peur de réfléchir à
l'idée de quotas il nous faut donc
regarder sujet par sujet on sait depuis
longtemps que les quotas ne peuvent pas
s'appliquer à l'asile ni à l'immigration
familiale
autre sujet sensible l'aide médicale
d'état
la ministre de la santé a défendu le
système actuel en souhaitant des
contrôles renforcés en france on ne
laisse pas des personnes périrent parce
qu'il leur manque le bon tampon sur le
bon document pour autant lutter contre
les abus
ce n'est pas affaiblir notre système du
côté de l'opposition le débat dans l'ue
à des positions radicalement différente
vous avez décidé délibérément d'injecter
une dose de poison méfiance et de
discorde dans les veines du pays
comment osez vous dire que notre pays a
été privé de discussions sur ce sujet la
famille le pen a raflé son programme de
plus 40 ans immigration ou invasion
c'est la question que posait l'ancien
président de la république
régis car destin à la une du figaro
magazine en 1991 est ce trop tard
je ne le crois pas mais il ya urgence
car nous savons que le 21e siècle expose
la france au chaos migratoires un débat
sans vote
mais le premier ministre a promis des
mesures concrètes en confirmant qu'un
débat sur l'immigration aura lieu chaque
année au parlement
emmanuel macron at il eu raison
d'organiser un débat au parlement sur
les migrations et maquereau a fait de la
communication sur un sujet extrêmement
compliquée qui en plus n'est pas un
sujet qui est dans les priorités de nos
compatriotes quand tous les sondeurs
voulait questionner ce thème arrive en
cinquième position
pourquoi il nous sort un grand débat sur
l'immigration dans une assemblée plutôt
clairsemé comment la version du sénat
un débat sans vote et sans aucune
annonce donc ça sert là pourquoi votre
avis alors ça sert à quoi ça sert à
faire tourner la tête à un moment où nos
compatriotes c'est quoi les questions
qui nous posent dans nos territoires
nous posent des questions parce que ils
sont inquiets sur le logement sur les
retraites sur le pouvoir d'achat mais
comme ce sont des sujets qui fâchent
emmanuel macron mais bon on jette une
bouteille à la mer vous faire tourner la
tête ailleurs et faire en sorte que les
médias parlent d'autre chose en même
temps est-ce que ce n'est pas légitime
de ne pas vouloir laisser ce sujet
extrêmement clivant à l'extrême droite
mais rompt personne ne l'ait ce sujet à
l'extrême droite personne sur aucun banc
de l'assemblée
j'entendais votre
publication qui parlait de immigration
ou invasion mais de qui se moque t'on
guillaume larrivé avec les loaded est ce
que vous savez qu'on ya petit de séjour
ont été délivrés en 2010 8 253 1000 vous
savez ce que ça représente à l'échelle
de la population française 0 23% de qui
se moque t-on en fait on est chez quels
sujets réels
donc à un moment donné moi je les dis
nous sommes nous les socialistes pour
l'hébergement inconditionnel
on n'est pas pour le séjour
inconditionnels mais pour l'hébergement
à conditionnelle ce qui veut dire
aujourd'hui j'étais la semaine dernière
à porte de la chapelle
ça veut dire qu'on a des deux demandeurs
d'asile des familles qui vivent dans des
tentes parce qu'il ya pas de places
d'hébergement est donc aujourd'hui il
faut produire si on veut prendre à bras
le corps réellement et ça je n'ai pas
entendu de la part du premier min ce
sujet il faut qu'on soit tous les autres
toutes les ong vous le dise
trente mille places supplémentaires
d'hébergement voilà ça j'aurais aimé
l'entendre de la part du premier
ministre
au lieu d'attendre en fait rien et bien
edouard philippe il a tout de même parlé
d'un sujet il a parlé des quotas pour
l'immigration professionnelle mais dans
les propres rangs de la république en
marche
au sénat on y est opposée écoutez alain
richard souhaite marquer une distance
monsieur le premier ministre fasse à
l'idée de quotas d'immigration qui
revient encore la plus grande part des
entrées sur notre sol vient de processus
de rapprochement familial d'accès aux
études supérieures et d'asile politique
seul de séjour étudiant peuvent faire
l'objet d'une limitation légitime et
c'est déjà fait et aussi l'intégrer
l'immigration professionnelle qui comme
ça a été dit et le plus la plus faible
composantes à peine plus de 10%
on ne fixera pas de quotas ni l'entrée
familial ni le titre de réfugié lucas
revenait ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette idée d'instaurer des quotas on
voit qu'elle divise au sein même de la
majorité présidentielle juste se
remémorer ce k bidy l'ancien président
du conseil constitutionnel pierre
mazeaud en 2009
sur la question des quotas et a dit
c'est irréalisable et inapplicable donc
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas aujourd'hui mais
c'est toujours vrai aujourd'hui et c'est
anticonstitutionnel et ça ne servirait à
rien parce charroi sur le groupe
regroupement familial c'est 90 milles
type de séjour on a dit qu'il ne le
ferait pas un edouard philippe que c'est
seulement sur les migrants
je prend décidément il a des problèmes
avec la constitution on l'a bien vu leur
essai sur la révision constitutionnelle
là ils nous remettent encore une
nouvelle couche sur les quotas pour
l'immigration
las la décision elle a été donné c'est
pas possible
le car venait en avance avec le
troisième thème de cette émission
le sénat a entamé l'examen du projet de
loi sur le statut de l'élu
[Musique]
à six mois des municipales l'exécutif
entend bien renouer avec les élus locaux
pour cela il s'est largement inspiré de
proposition du sénat pour renforcer la
commune et améliorer le statut de l'élu
quasi consensus dans l'hémicycle flora
sauvage en finir avec la fronde des élus
locaux
pour cela le gouvernement entend
renforcer la place des mères et leur
assurer un statut main dans la main le
gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale se
sont appliqués à détricoter la loi notre
lors de l'examen du projet de loi
engagement et proximité
c'est peut-être là l'écueil majeur
puisque vous parliez de la loi notre
d'avoir voulu légiférer de façon
uniforme
là où aujourd'hui les élèves sur les
territoires attendre un petit peu plus
de souplesse et c'est peut-être le point
le plus important que nous remettions
enfin les élus l'élu au coeur de la
décision pour son texte mois sébastien
lecornu s'est inspiré de largement des
travaux du sénat dans une coproduction
depuis le début avec une ligne de crête
à tenir c'est arriver à gommer tous les
irritants de la loi notre loi que j'ai
combattu en plus par ailleurs quand
j'étais maire et président du
département de l'eure sans pour autant
faire un grand big bang et donc que le
grand big bang aurait fatalement des
conséquences sur les finances locales
sur les budgets sur les dotations
si le projet de loire est plutôt bien
accueillie au sein de la haute assemblée
certains dénoncent un texte opportuniste
en moins d'un an nous sommes passés du
hashtag balance thomert au hashtag
cajole ton est lui bien entendu si l'on
est et moqueur pardon ce dont vous ne
pouvez me soupçonner on ne pourrait que
souligné
heureux calendrier de ce projet qui par
le plus grand des hasards et parce qu'il
est forcément très utile doit absolument
être voté avant les élections
municipales
après des relations tendues l'exécutif
veut se montrer à l'écouté des élus
locaux
le sénat doit poursuivre l'examen du
projet de loi
jusqu'au 22 octobre luc carvounas on va
parler du fond de ce texte mais d'abord
une question personnelle
est ce que ce texte est une incitation
supplémentaire pour vous présenter aux
élections municipales à alfortville
chouffot base et de questions
aujourd'hui je suis député et pour le
reste comme on dit on verra
la porte n'est pas fermée quand même moi
je suis conseiller municipal
d'alfortville et je continue à
travailler au service alfortvillais de
toutes les manières quel que soit mon
statut
je vais vous dire la crise des gilet
jaune à démontrer quoi elle a démontré
depuis un an que nos compatriotes
veulent que l'on a on leur apporte des
solutions à l'endroit où ils vivent
donc cela pose le problème des moyens
que les villes les villages que tous les
territoires auront demain pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse apporter des réponses
sur la sécurité les construction de
crèches d'écoles qu'est ce que ce texte
est une réponse qui fait la vie
quotidienne en tout cas ce texte
si j'en comprends la philosophie il est
haut en ce moment au sénat c'est de
donner plus de moyens et plus de
libertés juridique au maire est très
bien au contraire ça revient à ce que je
vous disais sur les fichiers s1 mais il
faudra pas faire du en même temps c'est
pas de dire je vais donner dans ce
statut plus de pouvoirs au maire et en
même temps empêcher un maire sur les
questions de santé publique de prendre
un arrêté contre l'épée style et de la
connerie il faut de la cohérence
évidemment et puis faut reconnaître pour
toutes celles et tous ceux qui qui nous
et que nous regarde que les élus locaux
ce sont les hussards la république 15 c
ils se sont lancés dans une danse dans
une vie publique et au nom de l'intérêt
général les maires encore une fois sont
le premier guichet public r1 mer gelée
et et vous le rappeliez un maire ch d'un
cat un body elle s'arrête pas 7 heures
du matin quand vous promenez votre chien
ou quand vous faites vos courses au
entre villes les gens vous à cause que
ce soit le dimanche soir ou lundi matin
c'est un choix de vie et bah c'est mr il
faut aussi reconnaître ce qu'ils font
leur donner un statut c'est aussi leur
permettre de vivre de ce statut on n'est
pas électoraliste alors ce texte
non je pense que ça va la suivre chaque
mandat à forte une réforme du statut de
l'élu
si déjà au moins on appliquait ce qui
existe moi j'avais un collègue ouvriers
malgré le fait qu'ils étaient obligés de
venir au conseil municipal
il faisait des trois-huit son patron le
laissez pas parti a déjà appliqué la loi
d'aujourd'hui alors que le dur car on a
120 terminé avec un vote qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue à l'assemblée puisque
les députés ont finalement rejeté toute
reconnaissance automatique de filiation
pour les enfants nés de gpa à l'étranger
la mesure avait été votée la semaine
dernière par le biais d'un amendement de
jean louis touraine qui visait à
faciliter la reconnaissance en droit
français de ses enfants elle a été
supprimée par un amendement du
gouvernement
écoutez les explications de la ministre
de la justice
nous respectons nos engagements à la
fois en ouvrant la pma et en établissant
la filiation qui va avec nécessairement
pour les couples de femmes en
réaffirmant bien sûr nous l'avons dit au
cours des débats et madame la députée
berger l'a répété qu'il n'y aurait pas
de gpa et en sécurisant la filiation des
enfants vous êtes nombreux à l'avoir dit
c'est ce que nous faisons et cette
sécurisation
je suis étonné que monsieur le député se
lignac qui n'est plus parmi nous je
crois pardon je ne vous avais pas vu
monsieur le député je suis étonné que
vous disiez que l'adoption n'est pas la
voie qui est proposée par la cour de
cassation et la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme c'est exactement ce
que ces deux juridictions écrivent en
disant que l'adoption est l'une des voix
qui est tout à fait acceptable pour
assurer la sécurisation d'affiliation de
ses enfants et c'est ce que nous faisons
et ce que le gouvernement a bien fait de
demander un second vote sur ce point si
vous comprenez vous relatez ok là
man issu de ses rangs il n'aurait pas
fallu que cet amendement soit déposé
dans le débat donc est-ce que vous en
tirer comme conclusion fait du en même
temps à chaque fois sur les sur les
valeurs ça marche pas le en même temps
donc on s'en rend bien combat de claire
il faut et il faut être clair et en plus
je vois pas en quoi cet amendement qui
rendait quoi finalement la gpa dans une
forme d'automaticité dans la filiation
quand elle était faite à l'étranger
d'enfants qui sont déjà existent déjà
avec la circulaire taubira c'est le
rendez pas automatique c'était sur pièce
donc l'asile et juste quand on parle de
réforme administrative c'est juste de
permettre aux parents d'avoir une
filiation automatique bon ils vont
regretter bien sûr parce que quand on
voit que la cour de cassation a reconnu
la filiation de mes amis le couple
mennesson qui a habite dans mon
département le val de marne
voilà un moment donné ses enfants il
existe ils ont des parents donc à qu'on
joue là en fait donc elle existait cette
reconnaissance avec la circulaire
christiane taubira elle aurait pu
permettre à des parents d'harry plus
vite tout simplement voilà on retoque ne
modifiait pas le droit actuel entre amis
mais non mais non donc top-5 fusion
juridique mon cas le bel ou belge
certains ont craint que ça ouvre la voie
à la légalisation de la gpa en france
vous avez entendu tous les débats qui a
eu dans l'hémicycle ça un jour on aura
peut-être un débat sur la gpa et
éthiques
après débat au lieu de on importe quoi
mais ça c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui
et de toutes les manières - la loi qui
passera mardi prochain selon vous la
montrer bien sûr je la voterai parce
qu'elle permet d avancer
après
tout gouvernement fait des avancées mais
fait aussi des loupés là ils vont faire
comment est-ce que vous jugez l'ensemble
du climat qu'il ya eu autour du projet
de loi sur la bioéthique
il ya eu des manifestations de la manif
pour tous la semaine dernière mais dans
l'ensemble ça a été quand même plus
serein qu'en demandant qu'est ce qu'on
arrive au terme de cette émission tout
cas les débats ont été de bonne facture
après que les les tenants de la manif
pour tous qui nous courait après dans
les rues
au moment du mariage et j'en sais
quelque chose franchement j'ai même plus
envie de parler de quoi eh bien ce sera
justement la fin de cette émission de
carbone as on se retrouve mardi prochain
tam pour les questions d'actualité temps
forts du parlement effectivement un
mardi à 14 heures à l'assemblée
nationale et on se retrouve également
mercredi dès 14 heures en direct du
sénat travaux de ces deux programmes et
à la semaine prochaine à la semaine
prochaine merci à tous
[Musique]